l'existence du mal est l'une des
meilleures raisons d'armer
les citoyens respectueux des lois
si la gauche désarme l'amérique
ces crimes ne seraient plus arrêtés
salut c'est le gouverneur greg abbott
bienvenue au texas
[musique]
mais l'existence du mal dans notre monde
n'est pas  une raison de désarmer les citoyens respectueux des lois
qui savent utiliser leur
arme et peuvent protéger beaucoup de gens
l'existence du mal est l'une des
meilleures raisons d'armer
les citoyens respectueux des lois
ce dont nous avons besoin maintenant est une
refonte de la sécurité de haut en bas à  écoles partout dans
notre pays
[Applaudissements]
chaque bâtiment devrait avoir un
point d'entrée unique
[Musique]
il devrait y avoir de solides clôtures extérieures
détecteurs de métaux et l'utilisation de nouvelles
technologies pour s'assurer qu'aucune
personne non autorisée ne puisse jamais entrer dans
l'école avec une arme
si  la gauche désarme l'Amérique
ces crimes ne seraient plus arrêtés
beaucoup plus de mères célibataires dans les métros
seraient agressées
ou violées
ou assassinées
les invasions de domicile
deviendraient beaucoup plus meurtrières car seules les
les criminels
auraient des armes à feu
et beaucoup plus d'enfants
seraient assassinés
[Musique]
vous